can we zoom in and talk about covid-19
virus sure I don't know what your
preferred name is but well right the
virus is SARS cov2 which is hard it's
long right and then covid-19 is the
disease so you could say the virus of
covid-19 that's fine it's a virus of
cover 19. but for the purpose of this
conversation well every once in a while
just say covid it's fine no problem what
is this virus from uh
I don't know how many ways we can talk
about it I think from a basic structural
like the the Varian structure biological
structure perspective what is it what
are its variants can you describe the
basics the important characteristics of
the virus so viruses are classified by
humans just to make it easier to keep
track of them right so this is a
coronavirus which is because
when they were first discovered
I think the first ones were animal
coronaviruses they looked at them in the
electron microscope and it looked like
the solar Corona and that's all there is
to it and I have to say that early in
the outbreak the the place with the
highest zero positivity in the U.S for a
while 68 was a working-class
neighborhood in New York City called
Corona can you can you beat that right
that's crazy yeah so coronaviruses they
have membranes right we talked about
membranes they have Spike proteins in
the membrane so they can attach to cells
and inside they have RNA and they are
the viruses with the longest RNA that we
know of no none other comes close for
some reason
they're able to maintain thirty thousand
so SARS cov2 rnas 30 000 bases of RNA
and some of the other Coronas are even
longer 40 000. this is a Coronas are
family of viruses that included
the what the the one you mentioned
before version one it's a SARS cov1 yeah
cov1 and I guess other ones so the first
we first learned of them in animals a
lot of animals pigs and
um cows and horses have coronaviruses
and then uh in their 60s we discovered a
couple of human coronaviruses that just
cause colds very mild colds that you
wouldn't even think twice about right
and then suddenly in 20
2003 there's this outbreak of severe
respiratory disease in in China
and you know they it started in November
and they didn't tell the world until
February and that was really bad because
it was already spreading by the time
they told people about it but this went
to many 29 different countries only 8
000 people were infected and then
stopped
and that was the first time we saw
an epidemic coronavirus and it what they
did afterwards is they said okay it
looks like it came from the meat markets
they have live meat markets in Guangzhou
in the south of China
or you can go and pick out an animal and
the guy will Slaughter it for you and
give it to you and then of course
there's blood everywhere and that's how
they got infected and they figured out
that there's this animal called a palm
civet
that was the source of virus the Palm
civets are shipped in from the
countryside and they the pumps if it's
somehow in the countryside got it from a
bat so they went looking in caves in the
countryside and they found in one cave
all the viruses that could make up SARS
wand
and that was 2012 I would say took about
five eight years after that outbreak so
that was the first hint that bats have
coronaviruses that can infect people and
cause problems right
and after that we should have been ready
so didn't I already start developing
vaccines yeah then so some people
started making vaccines they tested them
in in mice
but they never got into people
and some people started working on
antiviral drugs
nothing ever came of them because
you know industry there's no there's no
disease it's gone why should we make
vaccines and drugs and NIH in the U.S
you submit a grant and they say it's too
risky there's no none of this virus
around so people were really
short-sighted because I always say we
could have had antivirals for this
absolutely yeah for sure no question in
fact one the one antiviral that's in
phase three it's called molu piravir
it's the only one that you can take
orally it's a pill it looks really good
that was developed five years ago but
never taken into humans it could have
been ready so we dropped the ball and
then the next decade 2012 MERS
Coronavirus comes uh comes up in the
Arabian Peninsula this comes from Camels
and infects people but probably the
camel's got it from bats originally some
time ago but that never transmits from
person to person very rarely every new
little outbreak is a new infection from
a camel
so that was 2012 and now here we are
2019 a new outbreak of respiratory
disease in China
and this one really
goes all over the world where SARS one
could not it's a coronavirus you know
it's different enough from SARS one that
it has very different properties but it
still has a membrane it still has a very
long RNA in the middle and then it still
has the spike proteins that's right what
are the things that are what are the
little unique things that make it that
much more effective now to make it cause
a pandemic of millions of people as
opposed to SARS one yeah well The genome
is
20 different from SARS one say and in
those bases there's some there are
things that make it different from SARS
when it binds the same receptor H2 on
the cell surface so that's remarkable
um it has a lot of the same proteins
they look similar like if you look at
the structure of the spikes they look
similar but there's enough amino acid
differences to to make the biology and
what it is we don't know because
uh how do you figure that out you need
to study animals because you can't
infect people and the the animal models
aren't great you know for first so the
way you figure that out is you figure
out how those differences what
functional like how the difference in
the amino acids lead to functional
difference of the virus it's like how it
attaches how it breaks the cell wall
exactly and how the hell do you figure
that out like I guess there's models
you need to First you need an animal of
some kind to infect right you can use
mice people have used ferrets guinea
pigs
non-human primates
all of the above the non-human primes
are very expensive so not many people do
that
um and then you can put the virus in the
respiratory tract but in fact none of
them get sick like people do you know
many people with with covid get a mild
disease but 20 get a very severe longer
lasting disease and they can die from it
right no animal does that yet so we have
no insight into what's controlling that
but if you just want to look at the very
first part of infection and the shedding
and the transmission you can do it in
any one of several animal models ferrets
are really good for transmission they
tend they have nasal structures like
humans and they think you could put them
in cages next to each other and they'll
transmit the virus really nicely so you
can study that but the other thing
that's important that we should mention
is how do you manipulate these viruses
so these are RNA viruses
you can't manipulate RNA we don't know
how to do it
but we DNA
because of the recombinant DNA
Revolution that occurred in the 70s we
can change DNA any way we want we could
change the single base we can cut out
bases we can put other things in really
easily
and if I may
give it a personal aspect when I went to
MIT as a postdoc in 1979 David Baltimore
said here's what I want you to do
the the moratorium on recombinant DNA
experiments on viruses has just been
lifted I want you to make a DNA copy of
polio
and see if you put that in a Cell
whether it will start an infection
it's okay so I made a DNA copy of
poliovirus it's only 7500 bases it's
much smaller than Corona and I took that
DNA and I put it in a piece of DNA from
a bacteria called a plasmid and you can
grow plasmids in many many bacteria make
lots of them and purify the DNA really
easily and I took that DNA
and I sequenced it because we wanted we
didn't know the genome sequence of polio
at the time
and that took me a year by the way
because the techniques we had were
really archaic and nowadays you could do
it in 15 minutes right it's amazing
and I took the DNA I put it into cells
and out came polio
so that's the start now since then
everybody has taken that technique and
used it for their virus you can now do
it with SARS cov2 you make a DNA copy of
any RNA virus you can modify it and you
put it back into cells and you'll get
your modified virus out so that's an
important part of understanding the
properties of the virus it's saying an
animal by changing the virus you're
changing a DNA copy you're making the
virus then and putting it into the
animal can you clarify so even in the
RNA virus you can take and turn into DNA
yes and then that allows you to modify
it yes so uh what's that what's that uh
mapping well no no what's the process of
going from RNA to DNA reverse
transcription that's reverse
transcription right oh so you actually
going through the process of reverse
transcription to do this yes oh remember
David Baltimore and Howard yes have
discovered this enzyme in the 70s they
got the Nobel Prize for that and when I
went to David's Lab at MIT
he had the enzyme in the freezer he said
here take this and make a DNA copy of
Poland yeah I didn't make the connection
that you can use that kind of thing for
an RNA virus and so that's and then
modify it see that's DNA virus already
exists as DNA so you can modify it but
for RNA viruses it was difficult and so
then from that point on for influenza
every other RNA virus and coronaviruses
people made DNA copies and that's what
they use to modify and and ask questions
about what things are doing right what's
this Gene doing what if we take it out
what happens can you do the same thing
with uh kovid uh is it takes RNA and
then of course in fact in January 2020
as soon as the genome sequence was
released from China the labs all over
we're synthesizing this 30 000 base DNA
and getting what can you figure out
without infecting anything just uh
turning into with the reverse
transcription turning into DNA and
modifying stuff and then putting into a
cell what can you figure out
from that oh well you could well so you
you can cut out a gene you see some
genes in the sequence I don't know what
these genes do let's cut them out and
then you could cut them out of the DNA
you put the DNA in cells and maybe you
get virus out and you go oh stop clearly
that Gene's not needed for the virus to
reproduce at least in cells right or
maybe you take the gene out and you
never get any virus so it's lethal is
there a nice systematic ways of doing
this do people kind of automate it
absolutely and we I mean the problem
with SARS the covid virus is it's 30 000
bases a lot of stuff there yeah and what
makes it more difficult is that you have
to it's been classified as a BSL three
agent biosafety level three
and so not everyone has a lab that's
capable of doing that so it limits the
number of people who can do experiments
you know some we we're lucky to have a
few in New York City but not every place
has them so you cannot work with the
virus just out on the bench like we do
with many other viruses you have to wear
a suit and have to have special
procedures and containment and so forth
so it makes it difficult to do basic
experiments on the virus but well it's a
pandemic there's a lot of money there's
a lot of incentive to work on it harder
so and also you don't need to work on
the virus you can take bits of it and
work you could think say just the spike
right and say can we make a vaccine with
just a spike because that doesn't
require bsl3 so yes so uh like building
a vaccine requires you to figure out how
or antiviral drugs how to attack various
structural parts of the virus and the
functional parts of the virus right you
have to decide on a Target yeah like I'm
going to make an antiviral what am I
going to Target in the virus and there
are a few things that make more sense
than others usually we like to Target
enzymes
I don't know if you remember any your
biochemistry but you know enzymes are
catalytic you don't need a lot of them
to do a lot of things so they're
typically in low concentrations in in a
virus infected cells so it's easier to
inhibit them with a drug and the Coronas
have a couple of enzymes that we can
Target
so it's you've figured that out ahead of
time you can decide what to go after and
then you can look for drugs that inhibit
what what you're interested in it's not
that hard to do
there's just something beautiful about
biology about the mechanisms of biology
and I kind of regret
um falling in love with computer science
so much that I
um left that biology textbook on the
show and left it behind but I'll
hopefully we'll return to it now because
I think one of the things you learn even
in computer science that studying
biology
and uh certainly neurobiology
uh you you get inspired
here's a mechanism of incredible
complexity that works really well is
very robust It's very effective
efficient it inspires you to come up
with techniques that you can engineer in
the machine so that's that's the what
drives the field forward when people
improvise and come up with new
technologies that really make a
difference we have we have a bunch of
those now